[Music]
hi again everyone
welcome to theme 4 vaccine and
therapeutics development
this is the final theme of the
conference our first speaker is dr
sanjay singh
from india he is the ceo of genova
biopharmaceuticals limited
take it away dr singh
first i would like to thank manipur for
inviting
me to talk on such a relevant topic of
vaccine development and therapeutics
we as a global community is going
through this
pandemic caused by the novel coronavirus
having said that i am confident that the
scientific
excellence of human race will win this
battle against the virus
as we have succeeded through many
similar challenging situations
in the past yes genoa is involved in the
development of vaccine against
coronavirus
but today i am going to talk about
gino's effort along with its scientific
collaborators
towards development of vaccine against
the spaniards
a neglected infectious disease endemic
to india
and other tropical areas next slide
i have divided my talk into the six
small segments
just for the sake of clarity
the first one is the disease and
epidemiology
current vaccine and escape against the
lesbiania
our efforts towards development of live
and
attenuated vaccine as a proof of concept
product development from a proof of
concept stage
summary of the work accomplished to date
and future plans
with the live attenuated vaccine next
slide
so the first part of my talk is what is
the less menialistic disease
and its epidemiology
next slide in principle
the life cycle of lisbenia can be
divided into three hosts
human sandfly and canine
primarily this disease is transmitted by
a sand fly
and parasite reside in the host in two
different forms bromastic goat and
msd goat where metacyclic
stage of the promised goat is the
infectious form of the disease
these two terms are important for
lisbenia
promised the goats and domesticates it
will keep coming during my talk
sand flight takes a blood meal and
injects the promised
goat in the skin of human host or
canine bremesti goats are
phagocytized by macrophages and
multiply inside the macrophage and
transform
into mstable form which is the disease
form of the parasite
sand flight takes the blood meal and
ingests macrophages
containing mystic weights these
investigate
transform and multiply into promoting
ore
and infect the host again when sand fly
takes blood meal this is basically
how the parasite grow
among its host and a carrier
next slide
as per world health organization data
sheet
the disease is present in two forms
first is cutaneous dysmeniasis
and second is visceral insulin
intestinalis
somehow their patterns are very close
but certainly still different
geographically worldwide
today this disease affect close to 350
million people
in 88 countries globally
and rapid spread of poor populations
associated with malnutrition population
displacement
and a weak immune system
as per latest estimate close to 700
000 to a million new cases appears
every year globally and this disease is
responsible for
more than twenty to thirty thousand
deaths annually
next slide the first picture of young
kids suffering from
vessels meniscus where you can see the
spleen in argument
which is the first sign of the disease
in the second picture
is the subcutaneous dysmeniasis which
causes
skin lesions can be seen on infected
patients
next slide the next part of
my presentation based on the vaccine
landscape of this disease
next slide
so is any scientific
information is available in the
literature which suggests the
possibility of a
lesbian vaccine
if we go into detail to understand
the disease eradication
yes in a short time
pharmaceutical treatment against
infectious disease
has a limited effect to reduce the
mortality
and morbidity against the disease but
long-term use of these soma products
create a duct resistance
and a drug resistant parasite emerge
again and again
same is happening in this meniscus also
vaccine is the only possibility where a
successful vaccine cannot
only reduce the mortality and morbidity
against the disease
but also allows option of
eradicating the disease recently
we have seen polio has been
almost eradicated from the africa too
the vaccine is a feasible option against
lesbianism
is based on two important facts
first as acquired immunity develops
upon resolution of natural infection of
lesbianism
second in the past it has been
demonstrated that
intradermal inoculation of low doses
of the parasite induces long-term
immunity for both cutaneous and visceral
less meniscus
as reported more than 5000 people have
gone through this process in israel
and more than 2 million people have been
immunized
in iran but in recent years this
practice has been
stopped due to non-healing
lessons and especially the quality of
the product which has been used for this
purpose
though in the past different strategies
to develop
a vaccine against lesbianism like kill
parasite
recombinant antigen dna technology based
candidates
have not able to produce the desired
outcome
and as a result as of today there is no
license human vaccine against less
menialism
is available
so what the proof of concept we have
for the vaccine development against less
many assets
next slide our collaborators at usfta
through whole genome analysis and
sequential knockout experiments
reached to the conclusion that a
specific gene
known as centring if you knock out
it so selective arrest at the emestigo
stage of the parasite but not from
mystic
and as i have explained earlier a
mystery goat
stage is the stage of the parasite which
creates the clinical manifestation of
disease in the host
immunization of live attenuated dysmenia
and donovan
central knockout parasites generate
protective response against this many
western dispenses in this work we
publish
in plast neglected tropical disease in
2016.
further we have used crispr
cast 9 genome editing technology to
create
parasite where no marker is left and
this parasite can be used to develop
the product which can go to the human
and now merck owns the rights for this
technology
worldwide and this is also very apt
place where we can demonstrate about
what we are doing in this area
recently we have published the next part
of this work using
crispr case nine genome editing
technology parasite
where we have coined the term second
generation discrimination
vaccine and this has been recently
published
in nature communication in july 2020
next slide
first we have demonstrated the efficacy
of central knockout
this may near donovan parasite works in
candidate
using a science flight challenge model
in the hemisphere
in terms of mortality weight loss
and parasite load
very clearly you can see that in case of
immunized hemisphere
there is no ispring magali after
parasite challenge which is specific
to the vessel in this meniscus
next slide in case of cutaneous
dysmeniasis
we use central knockout l major parasite
vaccine candidate
followed by sand fly channel in mouse
model
where you can see in case of immunized
animals
there is no skin lesson a typical
outcome of cutaneous lesbianism and a
significant reduction
in parasite load as compared to control
growth
next slide we have moved
from lab research to the product
development phase
and the few next slides will show you
our progress
next slide
we have successfully grown the lisbenia
central knockout parasite
in the bioreactor starting from a cell
bank
where we can achieve the parasite
density
close to 50 million cells per ml
this was a long and oddest journey
but our industrial mind in area cell
culture
and artificial intelligence driven
manufacturing processes
help us overcome technical challenges
and reach this very important milestone
of a large scale contribution
of this knockout parasite
next slide
we have consistently produced glp grade
material
which have shown similar efficacy as
compared to lab produced material
in term of production and functional
immune responses
as you can see there is the expression
of interferon
gamma and tnf alpha in the screen of
hemisphere following
six week post demonization with either
laboratory blade glp grade material
or material which we have produced
through bioreactor
parasite load in the spring and level of
the hemisphere
either immunized with laboratory grade
or with glp great parasite
where similar post six month challenge
with el donna money
this work has been submitted for
publication
and the manuscript is currently under
review
next slide further our collaborator in
tunisia
at institute of pasture are testing the
efficacy of
glp rate material in the canine
subset next slide
in our efforts to take this vaccine
candidate
for human clinical trial we made
a specific effort in last couple of
years to remove
all animal origin component from the
manufacturing processes
here we demonstrate that we have been
successfully
removed the bovine origin heming
with us fda approved human injectable
great
pan hemitine without affecting
significantly
the growth of the parasite in the
bioreactor
as compared with the when we were using
the booming source heming
next slide however
our efforts to replace fetal bombing
serum
with human serum albumin as well as
with human serum in the manufacturing
process
were not equally successful
based on these results we decided to go
forward with tscbse free fetal go on
serum
for the use and we are in discussion
with regulatory agencies
under defined qualification guidance
successful removal of fetal women serum
from the final product can be acceptable
by the regulatory agencies next slide
we have successfully scaled the process
to the five data where the growth
burden and the parasite morphology
where source to the similar
to the small scale culture
next slide we have tried
out various formulation for the live
attenuated vaccine candidate
a representative of which is shown here
the parasite in the defined formulation
which is free of all animal components
are
stored in liquid nitrogen to see the
parasite viability of a storage in
liquid nitrogen
once the frozen vaccine is thought the
parasite growth is tested in regular
cultivation media
we have achieved the successful growth
of the parasite
in the defined media
next slide
so now we are in process of defining the
critical quality attribute
for the final formulation which include
first the pcr test to confirm the
absence of central gene
because at the high growth rate in the
bioreactor
we just want to ensure that no
appearance of central gene by genetic
recombination
or that particular portion of the genome
is exactly the same
from which we started from the cell bank
the second is the percentage of
metacyclic promissible population
and the third is their infectivity to
the macrophages
there are many strategies potentially
there are other many criteria but these
are the first
we have started with next
based on the data which we have
presented here
and also publications which the group
has
published we can conclude
the following next slide
we have demonstrated the efficacy of
central knockout parasite
in preventing sand flight transmitted
cutaneous
as well as visceral less meniscus in
mice
and hemisphere which is the gold
standard
further we have also demonstrated in
immunodeficient hosts their failure to
survive
in the sand fly vector and inability to
revert towards after multiple
animal passages
we have also shown that certain knockout
parasite
induces a protective immune response
and parasite specific t-cell memory
as indicated by the production of
dnf alpha and interferon gamma
which shows that this protection is
based on cellular mechanism
further we have established the glp
and gmp manufacturing of the live
activated vaccine candidate
so future plans for life attenuated less
mania vaccine
we are working on translating our
success at
5 liter to 100 liter cgmp scale
we are also planning to start a clinical
trial
in endemic region of india
and bangladesh
this collaborative program was usfda
ohio state university
medical university john hopkins
university nih
institute of past indonesia and nagasaki
university japan are involved
and we have been funded through nih
jhit and welcome trust
next thank you very much for the time
thank you dr singh for that great
presentation